the clock is ticking to save the world
from
catastrophic climate change but in a key
announcement
britain says it will speed up its
reduction of dangerous greenhouse gases
in the next
decade and hopes other countries will
follow suit
under the paris agreement almost all
countries say they'll put forward new
targets for cutting emissions called
nationally determined contributions
the uk has currently reduced its
emissions by 45
since 1990. in a previous pledge it said
it would cut them by 53
by 2030 now the uk has declared its
new ndc will cut 68 percent of emissions
within a decade the legally binding
target is to reduce
emissions overall by a hundred percent
by 2050
to reach net zero britain
is uh out ahead of most of the other big
nations it it's committed more than the
eu is likely to do
it's more than the u.s is likely to be
able to do it certainly more than the
likes of australia
uh have done but britain's promises
can't come quick enough for countries
like bangladesh
this year once again battered by
cyclones and floods
speaking from the capital dhaka
scientist sally mulhock
told me britain and others need to do
more
we are at the end of receiving those
climate impacts so they may
like to pat themselves on the back and
we have to acknowledge they've done a
bit
it's not not that they aren't doing
anything but they're
simply not doing enough and the enough
is what matters it is whether they can
affect the impacts on the climate
of the climate on the most vulnerable
countries and communities
and they're not going to be able to do
that the way we live our lives is
changing so we can reduce the amount of
greenhouse gases we produce
it's hoped the uk's promises will
trigger a new round of global
commitments
to turn the tide on climate change
before it's too late
lisa holland sky news